hello everybody welcome to Yale's first
teach in on the current unrest in the
Middle East and North Africa my name is
Marsha in horn and I'm the chair of the
Council on Middle East Studies here at
Yale University we are very grateful to
have this event today which has been
co-sponsored by a number of
organizations on campus including the
wet Whitney and Betty McMillan Center
for International and area studies the
international students organization and
the Arab students association or a SI
we're also grateful to the Dean of Yale
College Mary Miller and to the director
of the Macmillan Center Ian Shapiro who
are very encouraging of our doing a
teach-in on the Middle East and for
sponsoring this event and also I want to
say a personal thanks to Melanie boy
from the women's gender and sexuality
studies program who suggested that we
should kind of go back to an old
fashioned teach in about a very
important moment in our current global
history and so we think the best way to
do this is to bring up panel of experts
together and there will be ample
opportunity for you to come up to the
microphone later in to pose questions to
our panel of experts we're very lucky to
have these four special panelists here
with us this afternoon all are experts
in political science and history in the
Middle East and North Africa and will be
beginning where it all began in Tunisia
and then we'll be moving toward Egypt in
the discussion I'm going to introduce
each speaker very briefly and the format
is going to be that each of the speakers
will have ten minutes and I'm going to
be very very serious about keeping each
presentation to 10 minutes because we
would like to have 45 minutes of
questions and answers and discussion on
the part of the panelists at that point
we would like those of you have
questions to come up to the front where
we have microphones placed on both sides
and we'll proceed in that order and we
ask you to keep your questions short and
keep them questions rather than comments
and just so you know this event today is
being televised
so if you come and ask a question you
will be televised as well so it by way
of introduction I will be presenting in
the order of the presentations our first
speaker is going to be Adria Lawrence
who is an assistant professor of
political science here at Yale
University and a research fellow at the
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies she studies conflict and
collective action and is a scholar of
Middle Eastern and North African
politics professor Lawrence's work on
the use of violence by non-state actors
has been published in the international
security journal and in a book called
rethinking violence states and non-state
actors in conflict and she's scheduled
to spend next year in the country she
probably knows best which is Morocco she
will be followed by dr. adel allouche
who was a lecture in the department of
history at Yale University his research
focuses on medieval Islamic history
professor Oh Lucius articles have
appeared in numerous publications
including the encyclopedia of religion
and the International Journal of Middle
East Studies he's the author of origins
and development of the Ottoman safavid
conflict among other books a native of
Tunisia a professor alloush received his
degrees first from the University of
Tunis and then he came to the United
States where he received his doctoral
degree at the University of Utah so he
will be talking to us about Tunisia
specifically then we are going to have
our next speaker dr. Tarek Masoud who is
an assistant professor of public policy
at Harvard University's john f kennedy
school of government and a Yale graduate
I must add a political scientist and
Middle East specialist he focuses on
political development in countries that
are poor and unfree uncovering the
processes by which government's become
more accountable to representative of
and responsive to the needs of their
people professor Massoud is the
co-editor of problems and methods in the
study of politics & Order conflict and
violence and his articles and reviews
have appeared in the journal of
democracy foreign policy and the
International Journal of Middle East
Studies among others and you might have
seen
he published in last week's New York
Times an excellent piece called an exit
plan for a mubarek finally our own
professor Ellen last former chair of the
Council on Middle East Studies and she
does many things for our Middle East
Studies program here at Yale she's an
associate professor of political science
at Yale her research concerns the
dynamics of political oppression the
formation of political institutions and
the links between foreign policy and
domestic crisis focusing on the Middle
East professor lusts articles have
appeared in international interactions
Middle Eastern Studies and many edited
volumes and she's the editor of the 12th
edition of the recently published volume
the Middle East and co-editor of
political participation in the Middle
East and so I'm going to ask our first
speaker dr. Adria Lawrence to come to
the podium and I will time you ten
minutes
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here to talk about these pressing
issues I'm going to use my time today to
address two questions first how does
existing scholarship help us make sense
of the events that began in Tunisia and
have spread to other countries of the
region and second what should the u.s.
do when confronted with popular protests
like these let me start with the first
question what do we know about protest
and revolution the first point I want to
make is that these are not the same
thing mass protests and revolutions are
very unusual phenomenon but true
revolution is the rarer of the two only
some protests that demand revolutionary
change succeed and the causes of that
success are likely to be quite different
from the causes of the initial protests
themselves so the probability that a
real revolution that transforms the
political system succeeds is always low
and in the end it will be disappointing
though perhaps not that surprising if we
see real revolutionary change in only
one place in the Middle East but the
outcome of these protests is still
uncertain but setting aside the outcome
what do we know about why mass protests
like these are rupt one point of debate
among academics and the wider public is
the role of dissatisfaction with the
regime it's very easy to interpret these
events as the direct result of
long-standing widespread dissatisfaction
with states in the region indeed in
traveling in the region you hear little
else but criticism of the way government
is run its corruption and the limits
that are imposed on basic human rights
and it's natural to attribute the
eruption of protests to grievances like
these against the regime but there are
two problems with seeing dissatisfaction
as a cause of these protests and let me
make it clear that I'm not disputing the
sincerity of Egyptians Tunisians
Jordanians dissatisfaction with the
state of political life in their
countries in fact hearing the
expressions of their grievances the
voice that they've given to them has
been the most touching part of watching
these protests unfold but they're
probably not going to help us understand
when and where we will get protest the
first problem with seeing
dissatisfaction is truly a cause of them
is that it's hard to explain the
negative cases the cases in which we
know people are dissatisfied but
protests either are not happening or are
happening on a much smaller scale what
about Syria Morocco Saudi Arabia is it
the case that people in these countries
are more satisfied we can't take the
absence of protests to mean that the
people in those regimes are actually
more content the second problem with a
focus on dissatisfaction and a question
that many of us have been asking is one
of timing why now does the satisfaction
just eventually spill over the argument
that it's the economy and the recent
price spikes is unsatisfying because
these spikes have happened before most
recently three years ago at the start of
the financial crisis dissatisfaction for
those of us who follow the region has
been widespread for decades my view is
that to get large numbers of people out
onto the streets you need both
dissatisfaction and a change in people's
sense of efficacy there needs to be a
moment in which people begin to believe
that real change is possible and let me
illustrate in 2006 when i was living in
rabat there were a series of
self-immolations in the center of robot
in front of the parliament and these
were followed by friday protests in the
central square and rabat but these
protests were small they were quiet they
were orderly when you talk to the
protesters even the protesters
themselves did not expect that they were
going to accomplish much they weren't
joined by other social groups it
remained the educated unemployed who are
seeking public sector jobs now was this
because those were the only Moroccans
dissatisfied with the government
suffering from the economy that's not
the case in fact the per capita GDP one
indicator of economic distress is twice
as high in Morocco as it is in Tunisia
twice is low in Morocco as it is in
Tunisia but what's missing there was a
sense of efficacy political apathy was
the dominant response to these
self-immolations in contrast the
protests in Tunisia have had a broad
base it was not just the educated
unemployed but labor groups rural areas
that also joined and then the very fact
that people with different interests
made common cause made people feel even
more efficacious and Tunisia then set an
example for Egypt and we've seen
unlikely partnerships there too with the
Muslim Brotherhood joining in with
secular actors an uncertain beginning
the sled to a sense that the moment for
change had come the unanswered question
in the one I'll leave to some of my
panelists is what generates an increased
sense of efficacy in the first place in
Tunisia in the first place I can
speculate on the possible causes and the
combination of causes the economy the
crises of succession aging leaders that
made a challenge see more feasible than
it has in places like Morocco but I
think the answer is going to take us a
bit longer to disentangle let me move to
my second question and that's the role
of the United States there are two main
strands of thought about what role the
US should take towards these kinds of
protests on one side there are those who
suggest that the protests have provided
an opportunity for the United States to
rehabilitate its image in the Arab world
by demonstrating a clear commitment to
democracy and human rights this side has
made the case for backing the protesters
openly and encouraging the spread of
democracy in the Middle East on the
other side are those who want to
prioritize stability over democracy this
side includes allies and other parts of
the Middle East those eyeing the
protests with trepidation and worried
both about the consequences of either
and unstable Egypt or a democratic one
this side has been pressuring the United
States government to proceed with
caution to stick with long-term allies
and to deny the aspirations of the
protesters and issue empty promises
these views these two views while
seemingly opposed share one underlying
feature they reflect the world view that
the United States has a crucial role to
play in these protests neither questions
whether the US should assume such a
leadership role and I'm going to argue
today that the United States and my
remaining minutes here has neither the
will nor the competence to follow either
of these recommendations well and
instead what I'd like to see is a more
disengage United States and following
the lead of some prominent I our
scholars I think that a US that did not
believe it was in its interest to
influence the outcome in these
places in either direction would be
better for the United States and
possibly for the Arab world too why do I
believe that both views I think are
fundamentally flawed they're entirely
unrealistic and we lack the capacity to
implement them the first view and the
one that I find most sympathetic has
seemingly already been cast aside by the
Obama administration just as past
administrations have consistently
favored discarding worthy goals in favor
of stability in the region it's hard to
let go of the idea that the US will take
action to improve the lives of citizens
in the Middle East it seems like the
right thing to do and from a normative
standpoint and as someone who studies
the region it is but a look at the
history of u.s. foreign policy and more
broadly the foreign policy of great
powers in general gives us little
evidence that such a policy is likely to
be implemented because nation states
always put their own needs ahead of the
needs of others the best that can be
done is to argue that democracy
enhancing policies are in the security
interests of the United States but such
arguments often fail to persuade even
when some of our best are making them
though the US puts its own interests
first and it's unrealistic to expect
otherwise it does sometimes pursue goals
like democratization when they don't
directly contradict US interests but
then the problem with relying on this is
one of capacity supporting democracy is
hard the right policies are rarely
obvious mistakes are easy to make it's
easy to trust the wrong person or to
lack the ability to hold leaders to
their promises and when the going gets
tough the United States is likely to cut
and run because again it will always
prioritize its own interests over goals
that are from the US security standpoint
secondary and thus I believe that the US
is going to continue to disappoint those
who would play wish it would play a
positive role the US should get out of
the business of stating that it even
intends to do so it's no longer seen as
an honest broker in the region in any
case and its good intentions are just
not credible the second view that the US
should seek some stability is also
entirely unrealistic because it presumes
that the US is actually capable of
guaranteeing security in the region and
knows how to best go about it the US is
often depicted as an all-powerful puppet
but in reality us capacity is limited
the u.s. can be played just as it can
manipulate others events in Egypt are
unpredictable we don't know how it will
turn out even if the u.s. takes one side
or another and regardless of the outcome
if things do go awry if the u.s. does
not achieve its goals or if it believes
in promises of reform that failed to
materialize and ends up watching a new
regime that is even worse take power the
US will definitely get the blame the US
has imperfect control but it is seen as
decisive and this means that when and if
things go wrong which I hope they don't
we will once again be left with nothing
but the anger of those who sought
democratic reform it's hard for the u.s.
to stand back and step down if I had my
way the US would have issued statements
to the effect that it opposed violence
against civilians would not support a
regime that engaged in putting down
protest violently and prefers democracy
but is ultimately going to leave it up
to the Egyptian people I would have sent
the message this is your revolution we
are not going to intervene and what I
would not be doing I would not be
engaging in military to military
contacts sending messages to mubarak to
step down or stay in power or two
Sulieman and short I believe the same
thing that I did when it came to
invading Iraq that the United States
needs above all else to stop interfering
in the region and this belief is
bolstered by my view that from a u.s.
perspective there's really not a lot at
stake here the US interests are
compatible with a lot of the likely
scenarios that we could see continued
authoritarianism in the in Egypt is
something we've already been dealing
with the United States is used to that
similarly though it's hard for me to see
how democracy in Egypt even one in which
the Muslim Brotherhood has a significant
voice is unworkable or bad for the
United States some of those outcomes
might be seen as undesirable from the
point of view of our allies a democratic
Egypt could easily seem threatening to
the stability of authoritarianism in
other parts of the region or to Israel
but again if you take it purely from the
perspective of the United States is not
clear that this would be bad it might
create pressures that would force our
allies to implement changes that would
make the entire region more stable the
US has spent a lot of time ringing its
hands and vacillating and its response
to these protests it has imperfectly
sought a middle road seeking stability
and slow democratic reform part of this
reaction is I think due to the fact that
there is no clear right path here that
will serve us interests and given that
reality the US ought to have done what I
think it should do more often which is
to keep its nose out of the region
thank you our next speaker is dr. Otto
Lelouch
I'm a historian for a second I'm you
Tunisian so I'll go take the empirical
way here and as a historian just like
the same French east warren east war in
other words i'll be telling you an
empirical a story about Tunisia focusing
primarily from the period november
seventh 1987 now this date the 7th of
november 87 is known as the period the
beginning of cotton coat the change here
obviously slogan used by Benari and
cohorts after the Bloodless for all
practical purposes coup d'etat against
the aging president at that time
president bourguiba the founder of
modern tunisia and the first president
of the country from 1959 as president
until nineteen eighty-seven banati
himself I mean legally speaking and
constitutionally has in a way the right
to do so and I don't criticize him for
that as a matter of fact yes bourguiba
in 1987 was for all in my view I went
back to neva December 83 general 84 and
I was amazed to see him that way and I
was amazed that they even let him still
ruled the country as simple as that this
is the period of the famous bread riots
so called bread riots in Tunisia where
we have two weeks of riots protesting
against the doubling of the price of
bread etc etc and forgive at the end
around Jerry six or so anyway in January
he made this literary two-minute speech
and I could see without being a
technician or whatever that it was
edited God knows so many times segments
or whatever for telling Tunisians let's
go back and go back to the old price
prices that we had here etc etc so here
we have the
article 57 of Tunisian Constitution that
was custom made for the bourguiba Arab
we're basically will give I was saying
in this article 57 that the Prime
Minister obviously it would be of his
choosing will succeed them in case he is
incapacitated and Bernard secured a
medical certificate of a number of
doctor stating that Bourguiba was too
senile and too weak to continue as
president so here this is the beginning
of the Benari air the background of
banati himself he spent his career in
the military he comes from the Sahel
area which is basically middle Tunisia
around seuss or whatever exactly her mom
sues he has a basic probably equivalent
of a middle school education here not
more and then his luck around 58 they
needed some people to go into fresh
military schools to be officers and he
was among them he came back and soon
started climbing very quickly as a
matter of fact I met him once when he
was still come on down which is roughly
a major in the army I was talking to his
brother he happened to be there and
talked to many way that's another story
so here and soon from the mid 60's
onward he was attached to military
intelligence and that is his background
military intelligence security etc
relevant facts he marries the daughter
of a general and she he stays married to
her legally until I guess sometime
around nineteen ninety or 91 or so he
has three daughters from this first
marriage so here what did bonatti do
before them what Bernard in 87 was the
Prime Minister we had some serious riots
in 84 he was called in to be the head of
security slowly than 86 he becomes
Minister of Interior
87 literally four weeks before he
removed bourguiba became prime minister
and within a month that said forgiver is
gone so I remember listening on my
shortwave radio he made his first speech
when he did away with bourguiba
promising democracy promising that the
era of Bourguiba in other words lifetime
presidency etc would be gone etc after
all these Democratic promises and the
Tunisians were quite less police
including myself at the beginning with
some apprehension enthused at least
through the text of the speech itself
now clearly the first thing he did 1988
was make sure to change the constitution
specially this article 57 that allowed
them to reach power and what he did here
is he remove that and made it that the
Speaker of Parliament would be the head
the temporary head of state etc whatever
the Speaker of Parliament will not have
the right to be a candidate for the
presidency after that so it find a weak
person etc Excel I don't have too much
time to explain all this but anyway so
change the constitution basically to
eliminate any kind of problem from his
old prime minister in the future or
whatever and make sure to have a mystery
yes yes when it comes to being the
Speaker of the assembly the other thing
too is in 1988 was the beginning of
something that every collision will tell
you about and that is something called
the cast been seized been seized or the
phone 26 26 this is a solidarity fund
and I was told I was in contact with all
the time that even grade school kids
will have to bring the equipment of
their pennies and pitch in and
everything guess everybody and whatever
the bottom and should as every third
person every employee every company etc
etc the bottom line we are talking about
tens of millions of dollars are going
into this fund here and when it comes to
this fund it's not part of the bed
is not under the Ministry of Finance and
is directly attached to the presidency
itself so here basically Benari had this
cash cow or black budget or whatever do
whatever he wants now that he's rude we
we hear all kinds of stories about what
he did with this fund and whatever so I
imagined this just because became
relevant the issue of corruption
nowadays that's coming up three minute
but the next the next thing and probably
his undoing was in 1992 he marries a
second wife of Tunisia is his monogamous
in other polygamous against law he
divorces the first one marries a second
one and this is the famous or infamous
later Benari that you hear about
nowadays what her back i was quite
interesting she comes like he does from
relatively poor family she has eleven
brothers or sisters he is one of 11 what
did she do some say she has no education
some say she may have just great school
education or the like and she among
Tunisians she is ridic she was as that's
what she had at one time she was the
hairdresser and low and beyond me she
met bonatti way back some say the 70s
some say the 80s or whatever what we
know for sure is that she had a daughter
from him while he was still married with
the first wife because she was born
around 1986 and he married her 1992 saw
the gives an idea this is something come
all right now what we see here is from
soon enough soon enough we see the issue
up and this is the major issue nowadays
in Tunisia corruption of spectatorship
etc but the issue specially of
corruption to give you an idea he took
power in 1987 in 1992 there was if some
of you follow the French media or
whatever 1992 there was excuse me the
so-called couscous connection in the
French media this couscous connection
was his other french connection
the movie or whatever we are talking
about an international drug cartel here
where his brother that I said I met him
a few times with her own two year period
his brother was involved in it so we
have a warrant against him while he was
in France and supposedly what aunt is
what i read they smother them out
quickly or whatever but anyway even it
was in tunisia they have extradition
agreements or whatever and normally you
should be sent back to Paris this never
happened and he was sentenced in
absentia 10 years in prison 1992 in 1996
the same brother was found dead and to
this day have different stories
supposedly the official cover one a
heart attack but everybody believes they
found him shot to death this brings us
to the last issue here and that will be
the clan of the wife here everything
even will tell you that the most
infamous thing is the benally travel see
Claire and the more I read now the more
I just wonder what the heck no cheese is
unbelievable what I see here to make the
story short every aspect of the Tunisian
economy anything where you find a bug
that could be made is almost controlled
by her brother's Japanese etc whatever
or his own nephew Zach said wat arrow i
have here with me a couple of
testimonies up to big business mans in
Tunisia one is the shipping business
among some other business and it's
basically it goes mostly this way when
it comes to huge business they see a
business flourishing or whatever they
come to us okay whatever percentage for
me and this no I warned you it's
somewhat you will find you one deal with
bullet in your head that's your problem
that's it that's that's enough and of
course usually with the pistol right
here on
one talking or whatever and this this
would be the business that this have a
writing here cases like this yeah so
here when it comes to what happened in
Tunisia sir probably have questions
later on whatever the issue our
unemployment yes the issue of university
graduates whatever that high
unemployment among them yes and this is
I don't have too much time right now at
Jeremy and someone would ask is the
correlation between the democratization
of the education or whatever in this
annual deputy situation only have really
a huge surplus of university graduates
not finding jobs around or whatever does
not issue the second thing too is about
the person who started this whole thing
you have to keep in mind Mohamed
Bouazizi was no hero himself I mean the
guy the guy just like a common person
dirt poor he was trying to make anything
help his family or whatever and he comes
from sidi bouzid whooshes the interior
is still mentality why is a little
tribal little traditional to be
conservative whatever i'll say and then
what made it worse is here i am trying
to just survive or whatever and then
this policewoman 45 year old for this
woman comes and bugs me away not only
that what i wanted to go talk to the
governor she slapped me in public Oh a
big thing a woman slaps a young guy in
public in that kind of environment
whatever and that's what he had up to
here and decided to what he did so what
we what we see here you can see the
reaction was not as much oh because of
my unemployment because of this way is
just basically fed up with everything
around them and especially the feeling
of shame the way I see it visibly what
happened here I stopped a stop here and
hopefully you have some questions
afterwards
Nexus professor Tarek Masoud from
Harvard thanks very much Marsha for
having me and to the Yale a counsel for
Middle East Studies so we're only in the
15th today I'm going to talk about Egypt
we're only in the fifteenth day of these
protests and it's very difficult to get
any kind of critical distance on what is
happening I will confess that I had
absolutely no sense that this was going
to happen and I've been studying Egypt
for a very long time but I think like
all revolutions this was one that was
impossible to predict but is you know
obvious in hindsight because if you look
at Egypt over the last you know 30 years
really there's been a huge amount of
combustible material in that country
that was just waiting to go off you had
high youth unemployment high inflation
you had a kind of political stagnation
and oppression you know rigged elections
constantly a police that as we saw was
quite quite brutal with everyday
citizens but like I said this is
something that you've had these are
things that you've had in Egypt for 30
years so the question is why did it
happen now and of course we might think
that Tunisia was a spark it clearly did
give people i think this sense of
collective efficacy that a juror was
talking about before tunisia you'd walk
by a protest at the lawyer syndicate and
there are often protests in egypt and
you'd think you know god bless these
guys it's really great what they're
trying to do but they're never going to
change this system I mean this system is
deep and it's got multiple ways of
dealing with descent there's no way that
we're going to be able to unseat him
after Tunisia after seeing Ben Ali get
on his plane and his night flight to
Jeddah then you walk by the protest in
Cairo a new thing well they did it in
Tunisia maybe we can do it here so
clearly I think that did contribute to a
sense of collective efficacy but I'm not
sure that this wouldn't have happened
without Tunisia so one thing is that
there
has been a group in Egypt that have been
trying for about five years to get
something going precisely like this
they're young internet savvy folks who
have been trying to organize protests
using you know Facebook and Twitter and
all of these things but they've been
basically you know protesters in search
of a focal point so when there was a
there was last summer am a young man in
Alexandra was beaten and killed by the
police so they jumped on that and tried
to organize protests around that hoping
that it would explode and it didn't take
then there were the parliamentary
elections in November in December of
2010 you know you know I actually took a
leave from Harvard to go and observe
these elections because I thought they
were going to be so important and of
course the elections were rigged it's
worth noting that the Egyptian
parliament now has fewer opposition
representatives in it than Ben Ali's
Parliament did when he was overthrown
but anyways these april six guys tried
to take advantage of that they're called
april 6 by the way after workers protest
in in mahalo cobra in a town in the Nile
Delta in 2008 but anyways they thought
okay elections are going to be our focal
point rigged elections are going to be
our focal point and they tried to get
something going and very few people
showed up and it was just in the end it
turned out to be a kind of traffic
nightmare but so basically you know but
they've been trying and there was always
this huge focal point coming on the
horizon which was hüsnü mobotix eventual
demise and if you talk to anybody in
Egypt and I kind of replay all of my
conversations there was always this
sense that when Mubarak leaves there's
something big is going to happen there's
going to be some break and because there
were presidential elections scheduled
for September and there was not quite
clarity on whether Mubarak would run
again or be able to run again or
nominate his son I think that these
people were waiting for that and you
know Tunisia offered an earlier
opportunity but I think that we may have
very well have seen this later but you
know this is for the historians to
figure out we're not going to figure out
why
came now as opposed to you know in
September or Never but what we want to
do is think about you know how do we
make sure that it ends up the right way
and I'll note that the regime's response
to this revolution it the regime's
counter-revolution if you will was
really indicative of something because
we it exposed to us the nature of this
regime right previously we thought Hosni
Mubarak this is a guy for 30 years he's
been trying slowly to reform this
economy in the society and try to make
it more you know liberal trying to you
know make it a more attractive place for
investment etc and overnight basically
he disabused us of all of those notions
this is a man who in order to hang on to
power took very drastic steps of
shutting down the internet fomenting
chaos etc and what was revealed to all
of us is really that the basis of this
regime was not some kind of you know you
know you know electoral basis where you
know they co-op people through elections
and it wasn't it's not some kind of
social contract at the end of the day
the regime rule exists and relies on the
threat of force and you see it now with
these you know troops on the street and
so this is what the protesters are
facing they're facing for the first time
they understand that they're facing a
military regime and they're trying to
unseat a military regime and the
question is how do you do that because
you know that is very difficult the
problem is in part that some protesters
think we can solve this problem by just
having Mubarak leave but the question is
what happens when Mubarak leaves and
I've kind of tried to write about this
certainly constitutionally if you were
to follow the Egyptian Constitution
you'd trigger an election within 60 days
and that wouldn't solve anything because
this is a you know the prop the
presidency is an imperial office
elections are you know rigged generally
and and and you wouldn't have enough
time to amend the Constitution to strip
the presidency of these powers but even
bigger risk is that the let's say for
example we said we're going to suspend
this bankrupt constitution and we're
just going to have a negotiation between
the military and the opposition right
which is what Muhammad about a day is
calling for he's calling for a
negotiation over a new concept
just imagine mahesana bhatak leaves and
then you know you would have to wonder
if the protests would remain at their
current strength or if many people would
think that they'd actually achieved
their goal here and if they think
they've achieved their goal then you
could imagine the protest dissipating
and then try to put yourself in the
position of Mohammed about a day with
his ragtag band of opposition figures
going to negotiate with the very
formidable omar suleiman when you have
no crowds behind you okay I mean you
could imagine almost hit a man would
take these guys for a very long ride
okay and he could even pretend to be
negotiating a good faith okay but all
you have to do to make sure that this
process never ends anywhere close to
democracy is say okay and my friends
were here to negotiate the concert the
new constitution article one what should
the religion of the state be should the
state have an official religion and
right there you've now opened up a
conversation that will take decades to
resolve and we will still be you know
you'll all have children and and you
know grandchildren while we're still
trying to figure out what happens with
the with the Constitution and that would
just create an opportunity for the
military to consolidate its hold so
there's another alternative out there
which is basically to capitalize on this
you know opposite this the spirit of
opposition that is on the Egyptian
Street and compel the Mubarak regime to
first begin with Parliament to clean it
clean free and fair parliamentary
elections within say three months which
you could absolutely do okay and you'd
have to commit to some international
observers etc but you could do this
within three months and then you would
translate this opposition that only has
power on the street into a you would be
providing them with basically an
institutional position from which they
could actually dictate the pace of
reforms and you know we might say that
oh the Egyptian Constitution is tilted
towards the presidency you idiot how are
you going to house this Parliament going
to have any power visa V the president
but we don't realize is that part of the
reason that the parliament has always
been weak visa V the president is
because there's always been a majority
for the ruling party in the
Parliament and so that's why it's always
just been a handmaiden of executive
authority but if you had actually had
opposition people dominating the
Parliament there are items you can use
in the Constitution to make life very
difficult for the executive article 85
of the Constitution says you can impeach
the president with a two-thirds vote I
have no doubt that you could elect today
if elections were free a parliament that
would impeach Hosni Mubarak okay and so
my feeling is using the existing
institutions as opposed to falling into
this trap of negotiating new
institutions from scratch is probably
the way to go two minutes okay so now
people listen to this proposal they say
wow you are a stupid man despite having
graduated from Yale and this is because
you're calling for elections in a
country where only crazy Islamists are
going to win okay and these crazy is
amiss when they win they're going to
make life very difficult for everybody
for Israel for the United States for for
Egyptian women and Christians and all
these things and so generally my
response to this has been too kind of
you know present some empirical data
well you know in fact the brothers don't
represent that much of the population
and they you know they've been working
very closely with other opposition
groups so they've revealed a kind of
modesty about their goals and all of
this stuff and you know what who cares
at the end of the day you're either
committed to democracy or not if your
commitment to democracy is based on
whether or not you think people you like
will come to power then that's the exact
opposite of a commitment to democracy so
you know it there's a time here for us
to put our money where our mouth is and
in fact I would even argue to that if
you knew if we knew anything about
Egyptian politics inside of these mr.
the least of your worries if you look at
Mohammed about a today's committee
that's supposed to go negotiate terms of
surrender with Mubarak you know there
are people on that list who would make
any analyst and foggy bottom's hair
stand on end I mean I'll one man meg day
for saying who's a very nice man who
spent hours talking to him he's this you
know he's the sort of combination of an
Islamist socialist kind of fascist very
nice guy his father was the founder of a
party called young Egypt which you know
had a fashion
inspired militia Teutonic anthem you
know Egypt Egypt overall you know so so
the point is there and there are others
on this committee as well who are nasara
see you know who are completely opposed
to American power but at the end of the
day the question is are these people
committed to democracy or not forget
about whether they're committed to our
aggrandizement in the region I think all
of them including the Muslim brothers
have made serious sacrifices on behalf
of democracy that revealed to us in a
real way they're they're authentic
preferences so I'm going to end here
except to say one thing this question of
whether or not the US should be getting
involved or you know I you know there is
almost nobody whose views I respect on
these issues more than Adria but it's
sort of odd to argue that the US should
do nothing because doing nothing is
doing something you can't have had a
policy over the past you know 50 years
of supporting a dictatorship and then
suddenly say when push comes to shove oh
now we're neutral that's the same as
continuing to support the dictatorship
and I'll say this the Egyptian people
and lots of the anti-americanism that
I've referred to this is in part
fomented by this belief that the United
States has supported dictators and I
would always argue this is an unfair
charge the United States didn't create
the regime that they're just dealt with
regimes as it found them but now at this
moment where you could actually get a
change if it doesn't end up the right
way rightly or wrongly okay generations
of Egyptians of liberal Egyptians are
going to think that the United States
actually prevented them from having
their moment of democracy and then try
to advance American interests in the
region thank
and our final speaker is dr. Ellen lust
and then we'll have QA thank you I want
to actually sort of broaden our scope of
it and think about what this means for
the region more generally and you're
hearing sort of 22 different stories out
there one which says the whole region's
changed first Tunisia then it's going to
be Egypt that's gonna be Algeria that is
going to Yemen this can be Syrian and
the whole region is going to go up in
flames that's that sort of version one
okay version 2 which i think is a bit
implicit in the way that the United
States is dealing with the situation is
to say hold on to Egypt we hold on to
Egypt if we see slow enough change and
we sort of say you know make these
comments revolutions are messy look at
the sort of the photo the the sort of
the the problems that two nations are
facing then we can stop things we can
change and we can stop those top two
sort of the the Train of change in its
tracks there was an interesting sort of
out there today this has basically you
know some of what you wish to argument
you take depends on if you think this is
1979 and you're heading towards Iran or
if you think it's 1989 and you're
heading towards Eastern Europe in the
fall of the Soviet Union but either way
there's a sort of this polarization I
want to take the joint the attack and
draw our attention to a couple things
one is that I would argue that
regardless of whether or not Egypt Falls
regardless of what happens in Tunisia
regardless of what happens in Yemen
Jordan Algeria etc the region has
changed and that part's not going to be
drawn back that part is something we
have to deal with and that we have to
actually have to start having a
forward-thinking policy about what this
means and how we should engage and we'll
come back to that at the end the second
is that we can do better than wonder
whether or not this is going to spread
or if it's going to stop and actually
think about what are the conditions
going back a bit to what Adria was
talking about at the outset what are the
conditions under which we should expect
change and how should we how should we
sort of analyzes how should we think
about where where we need to be reacting
to before we get in the position that
the administration has been with regards
to Egypt that we all are in with regards
to learning about okay wait a second
what's happening here there there there
seems to be sort of two approaches one
is sort of a demand-side approach want
to know where it is where we're going to
see
rest next look at where people are
really unhappy really poor this is back
to back to adrià's point at the outset
there if you do that I mean there's one
thing to recognize which is the Middle
East is not Africa okay it's not much of
Southeast Asia the average the lowest
level if you look at something like
human development index in the Middle
East is actually a ma you know medium
it's it's not sort of the dregs of
society so the problem there is not the
fact that there is no income there is no
wealth there is no development the
problem in the Middle East is the fact
that it is extremely uneven who is doing
well and who's doing poorly both across
the region but also within countries ok
if we look in terms of sort of just a
basic where are people poor in an
unhappy then we find that of course in
Egypt we we had forty percent below the
sort of the national poverty line and
Tunisia we had twenty-three percent way
up there is Yemen okay with today with
sixty percent below the national poverty
line Morocco and Algeria with forty
percent Syria with thirty percent Jordan
which I would argue is pretty unstable
at eleven percent so there's a lot of
poor people out there if you want to
sort of simply say will the region have
problems in that direction then there's
a good reason to think at least some of
these countries well okay now this
excludes and you might have noticed most
of the Gulf countries are not in this in
this pocket of countries and of course
they've been making the point that we
shouldn't expect to see problems because
on the one hand we don't have the sort
of the poverty and those issues there's
a sort of a more interesting argument
that came out of some of the shakes at
the Davis conference which I found
amusing it best which was we also don't
have to have problems because after all
unlike Egypt where they said they have
democracy and they don't we've never
said we have democracy so there's no
problem it was clever I'm not so sure
that it means that really we can assume
these people don't worry about having
democracy and the other thing I'm not
quite sure we can we can really assume
as much as we want to is that the income
distribution is not what matters and
it's simply the level of income put
differently yes it's true Saudis tend to
do better than what we see if you're
looking at Yemenis okay on the other
hand there's a lot of inequality in
Saudi Arabia it's part of what's driven
those the opposition that has come out
in terrorist movements before there's no
reason to think the Saudi is ness
saraly immune to to unrest but the
second thing that in the sort of a back
on the kind of amusing statements but
nevertheless things that these leaders
are full holding onto is a statement by
Bashar al-assad in the wall street
journal which said after all we've taken
the right side of the peace treaty we
take in the right foreign policy our
people are behind us so that's another
way that they're trying to suggest this
if you look at what the leaders are
doing across the region you know that
they're worried right so we see for
example you know that in algeria they've
promised to lift emergency measures not
exactly clear when they're planning on
doing it but they certainly are talking
about doing it in Jordan and Syria and
elsewhere we see food subsidies being
increased we see government salaries
being increased we see in Jordin those
tax plus plus the the change in the
Prime Minister and the change of the
government being promised in Yemen also
promised by the by the president not to
run in the next elections as along with
the statement that he'd never really
plan to or have his son do so so so what
we see is that if if we're wondering
whether or not there's they're sort of
concern for this spreading across the
region at least among the leaders
there's been a very fast reaction I
would argue that they know about their
region better than we do there's been a
very fast reaction to suggesting that
this can spread now I would argue is
that how this would spread how hard it
would be what kind of timing we should
expect to see and even when our one
might argue sort of how disruptive and
how bloody and what kind of exit plans
we might see will depend a lot on
conditions are not about these questions
or so to economic conditions but really
are dependent upon the kind of the
political makeup in the institutional
structures of these regimes so for
example one of the things that we've
we've seen people point to is that
monarchies might be more able to weather
this then the Republican regimes to some
extent you know the argument is that
monarchies have legitimacy that they're
seen as sort of being above the fray of
politics that they can blame their
governments for the out for the crises
that people are taking and that they
don't get blamed so for example
Jordanians going out into the streets
and Jordan to argue that they're sort of
their high price high food prices in an
oil etc
say that we need to change the regime
they don't go out and say we need to
change the monarchy I think that's a bit
of a red herring because of course they
go out and say they're going to need to
change the regime at least at the outset
because saying they need to change the
monarchy is going to have a much higher
higher repercussions for them than
saying that they want to change the
regime so I would take it with a grain
of salt to the extent to that which that
matters what we do see though is that in
the monarchies which I of course for
those who they don't pop up in your mind
our Jordan Morocco for instance I'm of
course in the Gulf we have an exit
option and we have an exit option for
the royal family which is you can morph
into a constitutional monarchy and that
is of course the opposition's opposition
calls in Jordan and the opposition calls
in Morocco right now are suggesting not
to the king that he has to leave but the
fact that he has to sort of you know
give the government the real power and
they can sort of slide into the
background its kind of the the European
model the extent to which that one that
being an option though depends a lot on
the relationship between these regimes
their security forces their army and of
course they're sort of the the general
make up one we've seen in Tunisia and
when we look at Egypt one thing that's
very striking is that these are
relatively homogenous populations not
entirely but relatively so and so you're
not looking at a place where people are
out to get the regime because it's been
a minority that has dominated them at
the other end of the spectrum is a place
like Syria where you have a small
minority ten to twenty percent of the
population that dominates an 80% Sunni
majority population there the
expectation I think among the people who
can remember the fact that in 1982
between fifteen and thirty thousand
people were essentially bulldozed by the
Maya regime determined to hold on to
power that the determination remains
because that regime at least the
security forces around that regime
recognize that they don't have the
accident that somebody like Omar
Suleiman has they don't see themselves
as being able to change into a new
regime and and so therefore their
initial hold should be much stronger
it's not surprising in that sense and it
would actually make one more point with
regard to them they've also wiped out
civil society there's very little sort
of opposition in
inside Syria that has a call on the
streets that could make a promise to
these to these regimes and to those
around them that you exit nicely and
will assure your essentially will assure
your security there's nobody to make
that argument okay so the so the problem
of course is is the place like Syria you
end up with calls for change last week
nobody inside to answer those and nobody
willing essentially to put themselves on
the line because the costs are simply
much higher the point being we recognize
it across the region that we're going to
see different different rates of change
we're going to see different sort of
dynamics of change but then again we
should recognize that the region overall
is going through a change which brings
me to my last point I mean like Tareq I
actually and Adrian knows I disagree
with her on our sort of ability to sit
out it's it's not only the fact that
that people see us is involved we give
1.3 billion dollars to the Egyptian
regime we actually there is no sort of
sitting it out okay so we have two
options one is to hope for a managed
managed transition or to muddle through
or to hold out at all costs and to sort
of think that we can promote a gradual
transition the problem I think with that
notion is that this is a region that has
seen promises of a gradual transition
for 20 years the saw Africa saw at
Eastern Europe saw other regions
actually see transition and I think the
expectation is that you can't see
gradual transitions with the leaders in
power who they've lost faith in the
calls that they said they will reform I
think that that's a problem and of
course it was exacerbated by the
Tunisian example of getting on the plane
and leaving so now egyptian opposition
have in their mind getting on the plane
and leaving as an outcome that can be
attained the so the problem i think is
is that we have a hard time making the
call for this gradualism seeing a
transition go through and frankly I
think that the United States has a hard
time committing to democracy in the
region I mean we talk a lot about
whether or not Islamists can commit to
democracy and of course one of the
things that's interesting about the
Muslim Brotherhood endure in Egypt is
that they've they've called and said
that they wouldn't run into elections or
presidential elections as a way of
trying to commit to interest in
democracy and not trying to sort of
steel the cookies um we talked about to
some extent as an implication but not
discussed as much as it could be about
the weather not the
it's feel democracy but I think we also
have to be really serious about the fact
that the United States can also be seen
as an actor that might be interested in
undermining the potential for democracy
across the region for all of the reasons
that we've been hearing so the second
option which is actually quite in some
ways radical a bit bold and probably
unrealistic but nevertheless I think
needs to at least be discussed is to
find ways in which the United States can
take a broader more regional approach
that actually looks at and considers the
ways in which we could commit to be in
being interested in a democratic region
part of that is reopening and pushing
pressing really for peace talks in the
palestinian-israeli situation not
because that's the only issue in the
region but certainly by doing so we
would undercut Hamas we would undercut
Hezbollah we would undercut Iran and
those are important strategic
implications of what we could do that's
one example obviously sort of working
with actors on the ground trying to sort
of remove our interest in trying to
manage in and I we could talk about this
in QA but managed in much the same way
that we did in Iran what we're doing in
Egypt today which at the end of the day
do not make commitments and and and dry
it's sort of the trust of the people but
requires the continued efforts to
maintain security there thank
so we have about a half hour 25 minutes
for some questions and I would just ask
that you come forward to the microphone
and pose a question rather than a long
comment keep it a question and if you
would like to direct it to a particular
panelists please let them know and it is
again being televised yes dr. Massoud
just because I've recently read the game
ala means book about whatever happened
to the Egyptians and I wanted to ask you
about the role of the end of labor
migration into the Gulf and the fact
that now you know you have all these
Egyptian people whose parents you know
benefited from you know the money that
they made in countries like Saudi Arabia
now the fact that's how he has this you
know the Saudization program and now
these masses of people are not able to
bring that wealth back to the country is
that you know somewhat feeding the the
feelings of dissatisfaction is it has it
the fact that there's no longer that the
kind of social mobility that was
possible during that error when the
labor migration was at it you know its
peak and did that you know also that the
whole the role of consumerism then the
fact that they had that bat that cash
from the Gulf that could come home they
could spend to get TVs you know quality
of life you know is fact that those are
those hopes are for the future is now
what you know without that kind of money
coming in from from from the Gulf and
the whole labor migration is is that
something that the youth owes the
children of those people that been
affirmed that our feeling and is is that
part of that you know the whole might
that be a something that is feeding the
civil unrest okay yeah exactly that's a
really great question it's not something
i'd actually thought about so i'm not
aware i'm not sure that the of what
exact statistics are i will note that
some of the people who are at the
forefront of these protests are in fact
quite young and upwardly mobile these
are not people that are suffering
enormously and some have argued that
this is actually a revolution that's
based on sort of rising expectations
following you know the idea of the great
political scientist Seymour Martin
lipsett that when you you know sort of
reach a certain level of income you
begin to demand more but but I haven't
thought about the the relationship
between decreasing employment in the
Gulf and how that might contribute to
things that are squeezing people so
that's a good question i just don't have
the answer to okay question here this is
also a question for professors masood
and lawrence about the causes of the
mass protests in egypt i was wondering
if you could both speak to if you
thought that the alexandria bombing on
New Year's Eve had anything to do with
the mass protests that have developed
later in a month so so yeah I should
have mentioned this in my long litany of
combustible material right but there was
a you know in january early january a
bombing in alexandria that actually
produced protests it produced protests
by coptic christians which have
generally been a very politically
quiescent group in egyptian society and
these protests were joined by muslims as
well all of whom saw this bombing as a
kind of revealing the fact that the
vaunted security apparatus of the state
exists not to defend people from threats
but to defend the state from the people
and you know the bombing in alexandria
was an example that the regime responded
to those protests very cleverly and this
is why you know I was you know if you
had asked me oh well Tunisia happened in
Egypt I would have said no no and the
way they responded to it is they didn't
try to crack down on the protests they
just produced advertisements they said
you know as a double let that love tank
it get be upset be angry but don't make
a mistake don't you know and people did
that they would go out at the streets
orderly protest but there was no no
violence so so so you know the regime I
thought it in those protests revealed
its ability to kind of absorb protests
and but you know I think that was
purchased could have been me and just
been a dry run for the big ones or seen
yeah I think I agree with you that um if
we're not seeing these events today we
would look back and see well protests
haven't spun out of control precisely
because the regime is so competent at
dealing
with them and so I'm skeptical of our
ability to go back after the fact and
pick out the triggering points I think
the best way we can do that is to be
comparative about it and to again look
at whether or not some of these triggers
are present in other parts of the world
where we're not seeing protests that's
why I talked about the self-immolations
in Morocco which probably nobody had
heard about since they had no in there
were there were actually four
self-immolations in Egypt after that
what happened in Tunisia and so now you
know now have a relative conversion
factor of Tunisians to Egyptians but the
point is you know these things would
happen and allows our would produce you
know statement saying don't burn
yourselves and so again we would think
oh well I guess the regime is just
really good question here yeah I have
two quick questions first of all I'd
like to push a bit more on the point of
disagreement about the role of the US so
if professor learns could talk a bit
more about what she you know your what
your answer with to the argument that
there's no neutral stance what that
answer would be yes in fact I'm relieved
that I'm gonna get a chance to respond
to my critics so you know Torok
responded to my my suggestion that we
need a more disengaged us by saying that
doing nothing is is something in fact
and in fact he thinks that it's actually
coming in on the side of
authoritarianism and that's a claim I
don't agree with Ellen I think
interestingly I mean perhaps both of us
are promoting a somewhat unrealistic
view but she's suggesting you know hey
we can rethink our entire approach to
the way we deal with the Middle East and
we can move in a direction that truly
embraces democracy even when I would add
it will be costly to us but the idea
that we could stay out of something in
the Middle East is truly unthinkable I
mean perhaps both of these things are
unthinkable but i think you know it's
time to question this world view of the
United States as a leader as someone who
is committed and has to be involved and
has to be meddling she suggested so
because of aid right because we offer
aid we've been giving aid to Mubarak for
years you know
I think that the the evidence from the
literature and I are the literature on
sanctions is that aid really doesn't get
you all that much we've been pushing
mubarak to make some changes for years
it doesn't really get you all that much
so I'm not convinced that because we
give aid we have to take a massive
leadership role there I you know
personally would be fine if we decided
to withdraw it at some point but I mean
you know if we were through it from from
the region and didn't give us much aid
and therefore couldn't be as decisive
but I think this idea that because we
give aid we can totally sway the outcome
in one direction or another over States
what an economic incentive and what a
care can do the United States has been
trying to use these carrots use these
sticks and they don't often work now on
the point of about whether or not doing
nothing is supporting you know autocracy
and obviously that that idea makes me
somewhat uncomfortable I don't want to
support autocracy but I'm skeptical here
I think you know one it exaggerated
seguin the sense of the US has power the
ability to push things and to dictate
what the outcome is going to be the
protesters that overthrew Ben Abbey in
Tunisia they did that without the United
States approval or help or aid the
protesters got us this far in Egypt it's
my belief that authoritarian leaders are
mostly influenced by what's happening on
the ground in their own countries and
what I'm worrying about is letting the
best become the enemy of the good in
that the United States might instead of
doing what Tareq and Ellen suggest
instead actually come in on the side of
dictatorship and I see steps in that
direction that concern me so for me you
know let's take the good let's step back
from having an active policy in the
Middle East you know let's let's pull
back and try to to stay out because I
just think again that the neither of
them managed to counter the view that
that coming in on the side is unreal
stick and we lack the capacity to do so
do you have a great follower the panel
yeah yeah but ask your quick call
follow-up message a quick question is
where a lot of people are talking about
the domino effect a time where would you
see the most hope like for the next
country there would where we'll be where
would you see the most toe for next
country in their word we're under esket
you know reach if a good level like well
maybe Ellen should you follow you the
next most hope is that we how you put it
though can anything goes you wanted to
step back and say and repeat something
that age i thought i'd show you that we
ever get to respond to her taking yeah
which is which is that the we can be
hopeful i guess if there's change from
authoritarianism but but do realize that
that what we're looking at is not
necessarily democratization or democracy
installation what we really are looking
at is you know unrest that may lead to
revolution which may lead to
democratization so it is three steps
away from what an outcome that many
people probably normatively want to see
so just to clarify that in terms of
where do i think that there are as the
the highest degree of potential for
unrest if that's the question i mean i
would actually look at places like Yemen
i mean in some ways it the place i'm
going to pick out are not different than
the ones you're hearing a lot about okay
i think i think yemen is is getting a
lot of tension I think Algeria has hard
for me to see how they're going to lift
the emergency measures and at the same
time sort of managed to control things
in the ways that they want to win those
are places where we don't have we have a
very weak state in Yemen we have a
stronger state area but in both cases
they don't have some of these same kinds
of issues about minority security forces
entrenched in the regime that we do have
in a place like Jordan which I also
think is extremely unstable at the
moment and in a place like Syria where I
think if it blows up it's going to be
bloody and nasty okay so there's the
again it gets down to different degrees
of the ways in which we could expect to
see does he change just to note to of
one other thing and this is the this is
the point about a bit about sort of this
response about whether or not doing
nothing is doing something it is because
tend to be part of what supports these
regimes right and of course they tend to
be very tied strategically the United
States I think didn't didn't care a lot
about what happened in Tunisia because
strategically that wasn't a major issue
for us as much as it is for Egypt the
other places that you'll see a lot of
sort of might being put into seeing very
little change is going to be I think
Yemen and Jordan which for very
different reasons but both of them are
extremely important to us strategically
and I don't think that we want to take
chances of those cases next question q
my question by was actually directly
from this conversation about what would
what would count as doing nothing and
could uh you just say a little bit more
about the eighth that the u.s. currently
gives to Mubarak event what kind of what
what the eight is where it goes uh what
just just details of what actions are
currently being taken through giving aid
so so you know that our aid to Egypt is
about 1.5 billion 1.2 of which goes
straight to the military and then about
three hundred witches you know economic
aid which doesn't even cover the debt
servicing that Egypt has to do so you
know and I think that you know this is
not an insignificant amount of money and
if you look at on the beginning of the
police day protest jr. 25th the actual
the high brass of the Egyptian
military's here in the United States
they were meeting in Washington this is
public information and you know from
from my sources what I hear is that
basically they were told listen you guys
we don't want it we don't want to see
any T of n men over there and I so I
think that you know I think you can
actually we can you sort of influence
the outcome and we have kind of
influence the outcome and forestalling a
Tienanmen option I'm sympathetic to your
point Adria that you know basically your
point is we could do a lot more to
support autocrats and I'm saying let's
just do nothing to support autograph and
I get that and I like the fact that
everybody's attacking because I like to
be in that position but but at the same
time I just think you know when you said
I'm not sure that aid you know works or
is effective that's not even really the
pole
I mean who cares if they listen the
point is that if the people in Egypt
achieve what the people in Tunisia did
and they see us as having supported the
previous regime whether or not you think
that our aid actually enabled us to
offer that support then we're going to
have a very tough road to hoe in that
region and the problem is that we have
interests there we can't just leave you
know we've got a deep deep interest
there from oil to Israel and we're not
just gonna up and leave so so I think
it's a little bit of all the views here
the one that says that the United States
should do nothing as if we can just
suddenly reverse 50 years of policy and
be you know Canada no offense to the
Canadians here so unrealistic well cut
the United States has been you know has
been asked to do something is actually
wavered and done a little bit of nothing
i mean i think that in terms of Egypt
it's not that hard to not get involved
on one side it's not that easy it
doesn't make us neutral we're already
known allies of Mubarak right that
history is going to be there I actually
think going forward the prospects for us
and having a regime we might like go up
if we're less involved if people in the
region see us as being less involved now
on the question of eight I mean you know
yeah I think that we should probably i'm
in a night i said in my comments i think
that we should probably said we're not
going to support I think that we should
always say that we don't support the use
of violence against civilians that we
support the right to protest and I don't
think that we should I'm not proposing
rewarding anyone that would be an active
step for doing so so I think it's right
to tie 82 things like that I'm just
saying that just because you give aid
doesn't mean that you get that much of a
say over what is a very large outcome
the other country that we give the mo
say to is Israel and despite the fact
that you know numerous precedents have
put their own reputations on the line to
try to push Israel into peace talks
they've also failed to do that despite
the massive amounts of 8 so 8 is limited
in what it can what they could
accomplish now I'm not saying you know
we should be totally silent and say
nothing I mean I think we should just
not try to be the broker who works with
these various opposition leaders and
tries to negotiate who's going to be in
a new postman barber me I would agree
was gonna be stayed out who now I think
it's not our place to do that I don't
think anybody's proposal okay next
question just to keep moving yes thanks
so much for all your insights you know I
was going to say on the word Israel was
mentioned once but then in that last
question alone it was mentioned another
three times so 4 times total I'm
wondering if any or all of you could
address what the Israeli government is
thinking at this point um what are what
are their hopes and what what does the
u.s. hope for Israel to be thinking
about the current situation in Egypt
maybe Ellen would you like to take that
one yeah I don't know what the Israeli
government is thinking site I can I can
assure you of that I mean I know it's
clearly their response has been one
which suggests it is I think quite
similar to the United States response
which is one that suggests that we think
that changes changes fearful right so
they have been doing everything that
they can to support mubarak and and the
government in a sense that's not
surprising right and of course had the
the gas line of it was an explosion was
not a very helpful thing if you're
trying to make an argument that we
should assume that real politic will
actually play a role at the end of the
day and that you know if you look at
African cases even when South Africa
existed African cases did not go out and
attack South Africa so the expectation
that there would be a military attack
against Israel I think would be
overblown but it doesn't mean that
that's not that that's what the Israelis
are thinking you want to add
yeah can I yeah let me go I think I
think look I mean you know I didn't
mention Israel because I kind of you
know I don't like this idea that you
know people say oh we support you know
dictatorial regimes because that's what
Israel wants it's like I don't think
Israel is culpable in this you know and
and and i think that the united states
if we really care about securing israel
we can have both a democratic Egypt and
to secure Israel I mean it might cost us
more but if we care about that we can
weekend we can do it there's a great
line by our colleague Ellis goldberg and
i just wish i had uttered it and he said
basically you know there are there are
some folks on the kind of israeli right
who believe that you know with Mubarak
leaving that this is really bad for
Israel and Ellis was like look you guys
need to reread your Bible since when
does the security of Israel rely on
Pharaoh good question i'd like to thank
you all for speaking and thank the
organizers of this wonderful informative
event so you've talked a bit about
policy now i think maybe we can talk a
little bit about strategy I wonder how
can we push your policy recommendations
I'm one of the organizers of a protest
we had just yesterday on vanity plaza
it's all dirty with the Egyptian people
and I was wondering what should be the
role of us as students as activists as
concerned citizens be should we form
kind of foment a wider
non-interventionist movement as perhaps
professor Lawrence would have us or or
should we find some kind of negotiation
between you know Rufus the positions of
Professor miss food and professor lust
and professor Lawrence what do you what
do you what do you guys think is
actionable in all of this well how do
you feel that we can push the Obama
administration to seek more productive
policy in this region okay great thank
you adria do on the story well maybe the
underlying point that we would all be
unified on was that is to you know to be
an active voice against supporting
autocracy I've suggested let's let's
let's not even be involved on either
side but you know at least to be an
active bosun saying you know the United
States if it can't play the positive
from democracy promoting role in the
region which I firmly still believe that
it cannot that it should at least try to
do no harm yeah I mean I think I should
totally agree with that and could hear
your question is is an interesting one
because it does ask us sort of actually
what can we do as opposed to what can we
prescribe right and there's a couple of
interesting things that come out one of
course is that if you're looking at
you're just sort of watching Thomas
Friedman and co and others in the papers
you're seeing an increasing interest in
sort of being able to kind of push for a
push for a new Middle East right so and
if you looked at the public opinion poll
that just came out right there's a great
deal of support for you know on the side
of the Egyptian people um it isn't it
it's obviously hard to know how much in
which levers that you are there to be
pushed but it is a time when probably if
you're trying to convince the
administration to take steps that at
least in foreign policy may be more
successful than their health care
program was this might be the time to
sort of make your voices heard question
here thank you I have two questions by
me first ones about while back to Israel
one of the reasons you know given for
supporting Mubarak regime is that a new
regime would be likely to break you know
disregard the peace treaty with Israel
but realistically speaking how like me
is you know a new government to
disregard it this peace treaty and my
second question is well it's bit
speculative but it's about the
possibility of Egypt's as an exit
strategy for Afghanistan it's been
suggested that the u.s. does not have
enough troops you know enough resources
to a you know Egypt at this time but
they do happen to have quite a few
troops in fact right in that region you
have a lot of troops in Afghanistan and
for the past nine years the US has been
in Afghans
and with little progress and it's
hemorrhage you know you know millions of
dollars every day and it's so far been
looking for an excuse to sorta Clara
partial victory so can pull out with
some semblance of dignity my question is
rather than do that could in the u.s.
say that rather than keep these troops
in Afghanistan where you know they
aren't making any progress could they
not reallocate its troops to you know
help the situation Egypt for example to
help facilitate free and fair elections
at this crucial moment so why your
thoughts and this is an aids abstraction
I mean two birds one stone why not we
have five minutes left so let's just
take brief answers at this point I can
say something briefly about the
prospects are breaking the treaty with
Israel and maybe target as well but I
mean I think that my best guess which is
very hard to know since we don't know
what the the government will look like
if it's indeed it's going to be
different that the Egyptian people are
really focused on what's happening
internally that foreign policy or policy
with Israel is not going to be the first
thing on the agenda and also that if it
is on the agenda that it won't that
Israel is fully capable of dealing with
that government and offering these same
kinds of incentives to keep the peace
treaty in in force yeah I think if you
look at even the most radical kind of
elements of the opposition they all say
that they keep the peace treaty in place
i mean i think the relations between
Egypt and Israel would probably get a
little bit dicey but also I mean
whatever Democratic outcome we're going
to have here clearly the military is
going to want to retain some role and no
foreign affairs and that's clearly
likely going to happen and so the
military has no interest in any kind of
confrontations with this room can I add
one thing on to that though and this is
you know talking about and talked about
I think I don't know if we actually
agree on this point or dammit them and
friedman's comes out of this as well I
mean this is a time when you can say
look we can't necessarily guarantee that
the government would be as interested in
keeping you know keeping the blockade on
Gaza will be interested in some of these
sort of tougher you know actions are
between breaking the peace treaty and
helping helping sort of Israeli security
and so the this if you turn it around
one of the things to do is think about
the opportunities that can possibly come
out of the city there is an opportunity
to say to Israel look now is the time to
make peace with it with the Palestinians
I mean once you make peace with the
Palestinians then as much I mean the
peace treaty with this but the Egypt
frankly doesn't doesn't really matter I
mean that's that's one of the things is
to change that those dynamics and to use
this instead as a time when and I know
it sounds the unrealistic but if you
think about it so did invading Iraq in
order to try to create dominoes so maybe
one unrealistic plan could actually be a
good one but in the Afghanistan any
comments on moving troops right idea but
putting troops in Egypt if that's how
they understood is no no question here
let's keep that risk because I see three
minutes left this is a question for dr.
Massoud do you think that the displays
of muslim christian solidarity as well
as solidarity across you know for elites
and working classes is really a new
moment for egypt is this something
unprecedented or what do you make of
those displays of solid anchor you can i
ask maybe we can all take all of them
here at the end can you pose your
question yeah sure i well I had two
questions and one of them had to do with
US policy out we've talked a lot about
that so i'll stick to egypt a more
directed question regarding moving
forward in egypt and this may bring
tunisia in I'm not sure I'm comfortable
with your proposal of parliamentary
elections in three months as things
stand in Egypt what would happen in
three months is it would be won by
whoever has money which is essentially
the business class and the people more
or less that are part of the regime
currently and so I'm not sure that
that's a very viable positive step
moving forward now I I've been
struggling with this for days now of how
do
for it as have many people and there are
very few options perhaps a presidential
Council of vice presidents with devolved
duties from the vet with a variety of
the valve news from the peasant but
elections in three months just doesn't
seem like it would move us to a more
positive place any time very soon okay
good and the last two questions I'd like
to hear more from dr. Massoud and dr.
less about exactly what I you think the
United States should and actually can do
to promote our goals in the region
particularly in Egypt I look dr. losts
recommended that we strongly support
peace in Israel and sure that's great
world for that but i don't know that i
don't know that that's happening anytime
soon and that it has anything to do with
what's going on in Egypt I said not only
that but that's exactly what the leaders
of Egypt would tell you and I would
stress over and over again when you try
to talk about the actual problems that
were going on in Egypt before all these
protests started they would harp over
and over again on on the peace talks in
Israel and only talk about that so I
like sure sure that's great but what
what what can the United States actually
do to accomplish our goals I in 60 in
2005 I it to focus on Egypt in
particular I it seems like the United
States was possibly accomplishing some
real goals and pressure in Egypt and
making real change all right so do you
think that we can try to do that again
would it actually happen and is Obama
going to do that okay great and final
question because we have like one minute
and very quick and take you away from
American you know foreign policy in the
Middle East and Israel the timing dr.
masaru that's question for you the
timing how do you say that you were
surprised about the timing and I wonder
has the WikiLeaks and Palestine papers
have anything to do with that concerning
American foreign policy in the Middle
East and the Palestinian Israel peace
process that's one number two what do
you think of the latest initiative
proposed by dr. Hassan in heichal on
having a government that is built not on
autocrats but rather you know another
word for it would be the qualified Elise
from all sectors of the society to rule
and excluding Albert I and his so-called
CIA whatever was the neighborhood okay
and in one those are excellent questions
just everyone will get their final word
on any of these questions okay try to
answer all of these questions because
they were very good and that's answer my
little car a lot of time just the point
about the elections in a short time
frame so I you know I disagree with you
I think that right now you've got for
the first time I think since nineteen
nineteen a kind of feeling of opposition
spirit in Egypt there's no way that
anybody affiliated with the National
Democratic Party could get elected dog
catcher in Egypt right now and to
capitalize on this momentum of a desire
for change i think you know we need to
take this gamble of having an election
because that's the only opportunity i
see for this opposition to get kind of
formally involved in to occupy position
from which they can actually start
dictating the pace of reform you know
the proposal of has an in hegel I mean
there are all these kinds of proposals
that you know Mubarak appoint the series
of vice president to will you know each
have a control over a certain part of
the government it says you know those
could all work i mean my basic you know
orientation is i want to get some
elections going on to translate what's
industry into kind of you know political
power and if we could get mubarak to
agree to actually just appoint people
who represent you know the opposition
into key positions in the government
that might work as well but but in
general i think that you know to get
mubark to do any of these things there
has to be some pressure from us and that
answers the question
last friend thank you thank you yeah so
what we should do it instead of fearing
I Ron I think we should actually learn
from Iran that's basically if we look
back at what we did with with regard to
Iran in the end the fall of the Shah you
see that most of the things that we're
doing now we did then we basically
thought that the regime could hold on no
matter what we then looked to see who we
could work with and we we sought friends
in the military because we had very
close military links we decided that
nothing else in the region had to change
and we sort of continued to sort of
think about okay how can we keep this
under control as opposed to imagining
something different actually I'm not i
mean my point is not to go out and sort
of find or pick friends and in on any
and the opposition side and the NDP
anywhere else in the military that's
exactly what I don't want to see
actually here I agree totally with Tareq
I mean it's to allow the people to have
elections to work with anybody working
within the process and then two and then
to see sort of essentially what happens
i think realpolitik will play out and
that this is not nearly as frightening
as people as people suggested is ok
maybe Otto do you want to say anything
fish of WikiLeaks and it's in the case
of Tunisia it did play a role it's not
the major role or whatever because I
remember myself talking to slim our memo
is not member of the cabinet who is mr.
Twitter and what have you and he was
telling me sorry I don't the government
was blocking the site obviously but they
had their own ways to disseminate the
the WikiLeaks documents and everything
guess this is one second even the
content of the documents are for four
major documents and they really don't
add much I mean it's basically
corroborating what the street knew about
the regime sometimes a little more
detail or whatever so basically telling
them all the Americans is actually
thinking the same way we're thinking
about the regime then give them actually
more courage when they start with the
whole thing then this is one second I
have a quick question i'm raising here
at the end that is we talked a lot about
the issue of israel egypt or whatever
I won't draw your attention also the
whole issue of the future of these
dictatorships in the area I mean there
is the equivalent of the vector National
Socialists or the like among these
people i mean when when Benari went to
Saudi Arabia the first person he called
what got Daffy the next day got there he
goes on TV and gives a speech at rest to
the Tunisians which they put it online i
watch six minutes of it what they put
their most ridiculous nonsense you hear
or whatever basically telling them he
told you he won't run again 2014 wait
these four years no problems not worth
the killing is what this is that other
stuff fine now Mubarak so far at least
the public view he got two phone calls
that that were we know about one from
Gaddafi again and one thumb King
Abdullah of Saudi Arabia now Tunisia has
no real geopolitical wait we know that I
mean no oil or nothing what Egypt
traditionally has a huge geopolitical
weight in the Middle East and the fear
here is no coincidence but their fears
think this is Tunisia now if the
Egyptians will succeed there is no
question about this will reinforce the
whole thing I'm right sandwich in the
middle that would be my turn their this
way the system Qaddafi is not clean here
just if you know the area and the three
sons and what they are doing and the
billions and whatever going on this is
one now in the case of Saudi Arabia get
the whole issue is up it succeeded
knowing the weight of Egypt have their
own troubles with the extremists that
the Islamic fundamentalist this is one
they had their own troubles with the
system as such corruption of the mic or
whatever and you can see just more
examples just lately some rain in Jeddah
whatever flooding and people dared and
what have you this something like that
for a country they're spending hundreds
of billions of dollars on
infrastructures total ridiculous plus
the most important thing would be viet
kuwait the Emirates or whatever these
small states that if you have travel in
Saudi Arabia somebody in Bahrain with
something less half a million with the
problems they have with their CI
population already they're having their
own problems we
seeing his domino effect there is no
question about this so it seems to me
mubarak is not just reacting to American
pressure internal pressure or whatever
but it has also the entire Arab regional
pressure has take care of that's an
important point final quick it's very
very quick i'll just say that I agree
completely with Ellen I just want to add
that Iran I think it's an excellent
example of the problems of believing
that the u.s. can get the outcome that
it wants and that I think what we need
to be thinking about as we move forward
is not you know what the US is going to
do to push us one way or the other but
are the protesters going to stay out on
the streets or take to the streets in
some other countries and what are other
actors like the military going to do
those are the key things I think that
are going to affect what we get and from
the US point of view we can work with it
either way well I have to say thank you
for the excellent set of questions and
thank you for the remarkable
presentations by our speakers today
thank you